pour ces ados bonjour vous êtes le
commissaire de l'exposition lanterne
magique et fantasmagorie qui a lieu
actuellement au château de maisons
laffitte en principe jusqu'au février
mais comme ça beaucoup de succès ce sera
peut-être prolongé alors il faut
raconter un peu l'histoire de deux sets
de retard bashing ses fantasmagories
mais ça commence quand on sait la fin du
gicam début 19e on s'y intéresse on s'y
intéresse précisément ces fantasmagories
on les crée précisément la fin du 19e
siècle grâce à robertson en fait mais
c'est une époque il faut la situer dans
son contexte il s'intéresse et on re
découvre le passé médiéval en
particulier château en château en ruines
d'un château abandonné château un peu
comme des belle au bois dormant dans
leur sommeil fond des forêts il ya une
véritable fascination que le romantisme
et entendu beaucoup contribué à
développer donc on découvre les châteaux
et en même temps on réveille les
légendes que va-t-il se passer les dames
blanches qui était imaginé au moyen âge
les fantômes les spectres et grands vont
tout d'un coup revenir en force tout
d'abord à travers une littérature qu'on
appelle celle du roman gothique la carte
des livres qui ont passionné toute une
génération j'accuse en 1830 donc les
châteaux les livres et en même temps que
se passe-t-il on va découvrir aussi à
découvrir un objet qui existait déjà au
xviie siècle la long terme la note erm
magique oui ça existe ml et fx elle et
fx est en fête bon c'est vrai que
c'était un objet qui était utilisée
souvent par des colporteurs il à l'est
du village en village avec l'ordre alors
l'antenne sur le dos et les visites des
specs emploi fais des spectacles
donc on est vraiment dans l'ancêtre
quelque part des spectacles jour 1 mais
ces images
c'est anodine quelque part qui faisaient
plus ou moins rêver mais ce qui va se
passer précisément les années 1800
90 c'est que cette imagerie macabre du
roman gothique avec ses fantômes va être
mise à contribution par les lanternes
magiques et les fantasmagories alors
c'est un grand monsieur qui a inventé
tout ça qui s'appelle robert robertson
voilà robertson qu'est ce qu'il va faire
il apprendra lanterne de la mettre sur
des roues et ils valent à bouger
davantage hier cela va donner l'illusion
l'imagerie voilà moment et ensuite
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il a caché ses
lanternes derrière un drap enduit de
syrie il va faire ses spectacles dans
des lieux abandonnés dans le couvent des
capucines à paris le premier spectacle a
lieu en 1793 les fous mais gens vont
venir en masse et vont être fasciné par
ce qu'on appelle les premières ce
premier spectacle d'apparition de
l'image lumineuse 1793 précisément c'est
à dire qu'on est un siècle avant
on va en parler de la main à peu près
l'invention du cinéma à quoi
complètement oui ce sont les spectacles
de roberson ont contribué l'annécien sur
les mâts puisque ça va être un des
premiers a animé ce que ces images
étaient finis donc il va utiliser ce que
cet appareil qui baptise le fantascope
tout de suite progrès un nom un peu
étrange et prestigieux et une
mystérieuse et ensuite il va aussi animé
lui-même des plaques grâce à des
systèmes ingénieux donc faire voler des
têtes coupées par exemple animer les
tête de méduse bon cette imagerie
macabre attention il faut la situer dans
son contexte nous sommes après la
révolution les gens sont quand même
quelques pas encore traumatisés par cet
grand événement historique ah oui donc
les cherchent quelque part a encore
avoir une sorte d'autres peur une peur
irrationnelle et en même temps c'est
pour exorciser aussi c'est probablement
vous êtes vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est une forme d'exorcisme mesquita
celle enfin intéressant c'est à dire que
on est dans une époque qui est là
l'époque des lumières font enfin là il
ya la rationalité à la raison et ses
rêves de la raison et en même temps
ça c'est tendance et cette tentation qui
le dégoûte ça on a deux gros comme ça
qu'ils sont qui s'oppose non oui mais
souvent les apparitions de fantômes dans
l'histoire suivent toujours un événement
historique
il ya les redistribuant voilà c'est on
le verra par exemple imaginer
rappelez-vous le l'engouement du cinéma
français pour les histoires de fantômes
en partie
ou d'histoire un peu irrationnel au
surnaturel précisément l'après guerre
dont cdc récurrent dans l'histoire mais
ici en fait on est quelque part on n'est
pas dans le domaine de la croyance on
peut en parler parce que ça va paraître
un peu plus tard avec l'imagerie spirit
mais on est plutôt dans le
divertissement les gens qui viennent ça
vient de la rue vous préciser que même
s'ils ne voient pas cette lanterne une
voie des images à paraître c'est un
spectacle un petit peu qui est l'ancêtre
des maisons hantées dans le parc
d'attractions si on regarde ça mais il
n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de raisons
plus pragmatiques et les dire non parce
que c'est peut-être plus facile avec des
lanternes magiques de faire apparaître
d'aider des images comme ça qu'ils font
un peu peur que d'autres à jet ski et de
réseaux comme south que non non non pas
du tout vous avez tout à fait raison en
fait c'est le propos de toute
l'exposition toute façon nous montrons
que s'il ya eu une telle fascination au
19e siècle pour les fantômes les renault
et les spectres
c'est tout simplement qu'on a inventé
les moyens de les faire apparaître c'est
ça la technique est au service de
l'irrationnel c'est quand même un
événement historique
façon et les eaux qui font alors qu'ils
se servent de ce matériel de fin de ses
inventions technologiques
il faut croire que c'est vrai quoi ses
apparitions de deux photos n'ont rien
ils disent passer de la basique au
préfet robertson avait un rituel un peu
funèbre dans lequel il faisait
effectivement s'est inversée de
l'entendre d'encensoir une fumée se
dégager et projeté même ces images des
fois sur la fumée ce qui les rendait
encore plus spectrale on est dans un
rituel presque né des gros manques
quelque part donc effectivement les gens
à l'époque
ne savent pas trop ce que voit on se
doute que c'est peut-être quelque chose
de son naturel en fait donc il va
beaucoup jouer de ça mais il va y avoir
un autre invention dont nous parlons
dans l'exposition celle de la
photographie qui va également contribuer
à cette fascination du fantôme puisque
la photographie spirit apparaît
précisément 1870 c'est très différent de
spectacles de fantasmagorie il n'est pas
question de lanternes magiques et
pourtant c'est très similaire puisque on
verra apparaître sur les plaques de
photographique derrière les personnages
qui pourraient normalement des spectres
blanc très inspirées de l'imagerie
romantique d'ailleurs toujours voilà
vingt et cent et c'est un invention une
apparition qui va bouleverser les
esprits à l'époque à tel point que on va
croire que l'on pouvait faire pire est
invisible photographier les séries on
les voit pas on voit pas avec nos yeux
mais avec l appareil de photo ils
apparaissent mais elle a encore parce
que voilà où c'est des portraits de
personnes et puis derrière il ya une
sorte nombre qui se profile c'est une
technique voulu ou est-ce que parfois
c'est ça arrive avec des imperfections
de le photographier et j'ai pas une
image qui se projette comme ça qu'ils
deviennent un peu blanche est-ce que
c'est voulu ou c'est involontaire puis
on se dit il ya un fantôme alors bien
sûr tout ceci pourrait faire sourire de
nos jours rien enrayé les sont les trucs
mais à l'époque c'est totalement
volontaire le 1er août et au graff et
américains s'appellent de nous il ya
même leur et en 1870 c'est le premier à
faire croire que l'on peut photographier
les esprits bien entendu il y a un truc
est ce qui va se passer l'année lé des
anecdotes vaut la peine d'être racontée
elle est amusante c'est qu'un jour un
client de ce même l'air voix reconnaît
en fantôme un personnage qui l'a croisé
dans la rue donc qui va comprendre que
finalement même l'air photographier de
vraies personnes en les faisant passer
pour des fantômes tout simplement grâce
au procédé de surimpression résultats
procès me lemaire est obligé de dévoiler
bien entendu que tout n'est qu'une
supercherie et pendant quelques années
seulement la photographie spirit va
perdre sa crédibilité mais elle va
ressurgir en angleterre avec d'autres
photographes et également en france avec
par exemple edouard existe depuis
guettés un des plus grands photographes
spirit qui lui même à son tour va être
jugé va devoir dévoiler ses trucs donc
toute cette période est extraordinaire
parce que on est dans une chasse aux
fantômes aux vrais et aux fantômes je
reviens ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que ce groupe entre
l'irrationnel rationnelle vous disiez
idée procès pour les photos je reviens
mais magicien les musiciens aussi
bourrin vont être un peu vexé aux dix
ans mais au fond on utilise nos
techniques pour faire croire à quelque
chose qui n'existe pas tout à fait
effectivement nous évoquons cet aspect
dans l'exposition il va se passer
également un phénomène assez
extraordinaire de lutte de combat
littéralement entre les médiums et donc
faisait
croire à ses apparitions
là nous évoquions la photographie spirit
mieux pour des séances pyrite on le voit
très bien si vous avez vu le dernier
film de woody allen est exactement cet
intérêt ce sujet sont des magiciens que
vous dénoncez voilà quelque chose qui
paraît est donc aussi un magicien pour
commis savent très bien le même faire à
part et des fantômes sur scène
puisqu'ils se sont accaparé ces
thématiques macabre déjà dans leur
spectacle ils vont à leur tour dénoncé
finalement les pratiques des médiums
donc c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
pendant plus d'une cinquantaine d'années
robert houdin
fini le georges méliès plus tardivement
vont être mis à contribution et vont
eux-mêmes dévoiler ses trucs dans leur
spectacle on verra même schéma liesse
des farces comico spirit qui montreront
des fausses séance de
spiritisme et comment finalement vous
faisait croire à ses apparitions donc
c'est passionnant parce que finalement
le fantôme à ce moment là et dans le
domaine de l'illusion et en même temps
de la croyance ces deux camps quelque
part qui s'affrontent qui s'affrontent
et à coups de trucs de dévoiler ou non
le plus grand celui qui a le combattu le
plus toute sa vie ces phénomènes bien
entendu c'est robert houdin c'est en
france et harry houdini et audi mais on
n'a pas dit culié puisqu'il a fait
vraiment une sorte de croisade on arrive
à dionne ya il ya dans l'exposition est
une chose assez exceptionnelle de civray
toute cette exception avoir parlé à dire
mais c'est une apparition avec les pâtes
de verre
alors ça commence à gonfler ça
fonctionne et quel succès ça a eu alors
là on peut dire quelque part que les
magiciens ont contribué un tendre il a
développé sur scène sur les scènes de
théâtre des apparitions au même moment
les médiums utilisés la lanterne magique
pendant les séances pour faire
apparaître l'image sur un voilage ou sur
un globe de verre dans toutes ces
techniques sont très connus à l'époque
mais il y en a une qui va bouleverser
littéralement la représentation du
franc'off fantôme au théâtre c'est ce
qu'on appelle en anglais le pps ghost le
fantôme de pepper peppers en fait est
l'inventeur de cette
technique très simple à la base il
s'agit de mettre sur une scène de
théâtre une grande vitres incliné le
l'acteur qui joue le rôle du fantôme se
trouve dans la fosse de théâtre son
image grâce à une très forte lumière est
reflétée sur la vitre est ce que les
spectateurs voient c'est finalement une
apparition très concrète une certaine
façon qui peut avoir une certaine
interactivité avec les comédiens c'est
une invention en 1870 complètement
révolutionnaire à tel point que le
directeur de théâtre vont appeler les
vitriers en leur demandant des grandes
vitres pour l'heure et la trier vont
répondre ne pouvons pas vous fournir
nous sommes à court de vite c'est à
cause du fantôme donc pendant vraiment
30 au moins trente années en angleterre
avec des peurs et en france grâce à un
magicien qui s'appelle henri robin qui
va lui-même développé cette technique on
va voir apparaître des fantômes partout
cette extraordinaire cet engouement il
faut aussi leur place est dans le conte
est incorrect c'est pourquoi tout
simplement beaucoup de technologies les
révolutions industrielles et souvent
trop de progrès un site des fois allez
un petit peu se tourner vers un ailleurs
en l'occurrence l'invisible merci
beaucoup et bravo pour cette exposition
qui est beaucoup château dillon la fidh
juste un mot parce que c'est nos terres
magiques qui vous fait peur pendant très
longtemps après elles vont servir tout à
fait autre chose l on veut servir pour
les enfants dans tout à fait en 1850
finalement la lanterne magique va se
démocratiser on va le fabriquer en série
et les familles vont pouvoir en acheter
et montrer des images finalement plutôt
orienté vers les contes de fées une
paysage un peu exotique à leurs enfants
donc il ya une phrase très célèbre qui
la lanterne de ce nom après avoir fait
peur à nos ancêtres va amuser nos
petits-enfants et c'est ce qui s'est
précisément passé c'est ce que nous
montrons dans l'exposition grâce aux
objets de la collection français
binétruy une centaine d'objets anciens
et de jouer d'optique extraordinaire
certains découvrir ici et qui montrent
effectivement cette transition vers le
cinéma bien servi et mon cerveau